vous savez en grâce il va dans la rue il
fait des magnétos il pose une question
est en fait quand ils arrivent devant la
personne il pose une toute autre
question
regardez soutenez votre ami il celui que
j'aime énormément et andres demain il
sera là il sera sur le plateau à l'échec
il a un nouveau truc vous allez voir ce
qu'il a fait dans public c'est
exceptionnel mais regardez ça ça ça fait
partie de ses tubes il est là lorsque
vous savez ce que c'est que le black
friday
oui assainissement et espère obtenir sa
merci je suis avec livia cleptomane
dépit l'âge de 16 ans qui vient de
dérober ses grands chez monop
par contre vous avez laissé l'antivol
dessus ouais c'est pas à moi pourquoi
mais est ce que vous savez ce que c'est
que le black friday cloud et robben nous
répondre à ça parce caméra on dit que je
suis avec marie henriette marie
henriette qui sortent de son cours de
pole dance avec ses petites affaires
comment ça s'est passé non je ne suis
pas d'un cours d'eau alors est ce que
vous savez ce que c'est le black friday
bien sûr ça vous dérangerait de me
répondre à ça parce que moi je suis avec
ce qu'il reste de larusso et après une
bataille d'eau qu'est ce que c'est que
black friday ça va très vite
ben oui je connais je suis avec jean
baptiste cleptomane qui carottes des
peignoirs dans les hôtels et ses
partenaires n'ont pas du tout jeune âge
tazara volts bah ça se voit moi je vais
te demander si tu sais ce que c'est que
le black friday wear 3 1
je suis avec arman experts comptables la
semaine mais frotteur le week-end sur la
ligne 4
votre taille des bateaux je suis avec
van der baader qui étudiants la semaine
mais frotteur le week-end sur la ligne
car je veux entretenir sa merci beaucoup
je suis avec josé josé qui est venu avec
son groupe d'amis repensée du gilet
jaune
oui bien sûr foot et gilet jaune
est ce que pour nous tenir sociaux merci
beaucoup je suis avec maria luisa morgan
vous étiez venu avec son crew pour en
découdre avec les crs
vous parlez des gilet jaune moriba j'en
suis nourri c'est vrai comment vous
appelez valable marie est ce que vous
pouvez faire ça se passe comme ça cinéma
niveau merci à vous je suis avec mary
mary qui revient que ses amis pour en
découdre
[Applaudissements]